hey it's me again in this video we're
going to talk about too much calcium I
want to teach you something I want to
teach you the relationship between
symptom and root cause and when we're
talking about all these symptoms of high
calcium we don't want to get into is
treating these all separately because
then we're going around in circles
there is a huge relationship between too
much calcium and what I mean by too much
calcium is I'm talking about calcium
that is locked up in your body that's
unable to transport in the body it's
stuck there there's other names for too
much calcium like hyper calcium 'ya in
the blood but if you're over the age of
50 and you're female and you're taking
calcium and you're taking calcium
carbonate you want to watch this video
because calcium carbonate is basically
limestone you'd be better off chewing on
the cement out there because it's just
rocks you'll end up having a lot of
these problems because you're taking the
wrong type of calcium and you're not
taking the other factors to deliver this
calcium into the tissues so if someone
has too much calcium or too much
unavailable calcium they will get some
bone pain they'll have insomnia because
especially of the heads let's say you're
exhausted you need to sleep but your
head won't turn off it's very active it
won't go to sleep that means you have
too much calcium I'll talk about the
remedies in a little bit but that that's
one of the symptoms soft tissue
calcification this calcium kind of
starts plugging up all the soft tissues
like of the kidney as a kidney stone
the gallbladder has gall stones arteries
as plaquing the eyes as cataracts
arthritis bursitis tendinitis all the
itis and that's just because the calcium
is not able to be mobilized then we get
constipation constipation is one symptom
of too much calcium why because calcium
causes a contraction of the smooth
muscle that's why it causes bronchial
spasm two of the lung or asthma symptoms
because there's too much contraction and
not enough relaxation excessive
urination
that's one symptom as well this could
come from diabetes and other things but
too much calcium is one of the symptoms
of too excessive urination then we have
them cramps like muscle cramps
especially at night if your toes start
bending like this and you flex them and
it starts cramping that's too much
calcium anxiety yeah anxiety is one of
the symptoms arrhythmias that's a big
one high blood pressure if you think
about one of the treatments to high
blood pressure they use calcium channel
blockers now what do they mean by
calcium channel blockers all they're
doing is they're blocking calcium
because it got too much calcium the
opposing mineral to calcium is magnesium
and that is one of the best natural
calcium channel blocker that you can get
but why not just take something like
that to mobilize the calcium so we have
to understand what is the root cause and
again this could also be a symptom of
these lacking of these other factors
that and that's what I'm going to talk
about next so how do you develop too
much calcium number one you become
deficient in the fat soluble vitamins
that would be vitamin specifically
vitamin D vitamin k2 and by them an F
which is basically the essential fatty
acids that would be like fish oils
because if you think about when people
take fish oil they usually take it for
arrhythmias high blood pressure asthma
cramps constipation arthritis they take
these remedies but they don't realize
what they're doing is just mobilizing
calcium to improve the symptoms so
vitamin d3 you could also end up in a
situation this is very rare but you
could take too much vitamin D and not
enough of the other ones right here and
end up with this problem too because
vitamin D increases the absorption of
calcium but it only will increase it up
into the blood it doesn't push it into
the tissue so it can plug everything up
and that's why I always recommend if you
going to take calcium always take
vitamin d3 with it and k2 and I take
10,000 IU's of vitamin d3 and then I
would take a hundred micrograms of
vitamin k2 and you might it's not k1 so
you're going to have to get the right
one k2 is quite amazing because it will
clean up the calcium in the arteries the
calcification it cleans up the calcium
and the soft tissues vitamin k2 will
even help these other symptoms blood
pressure and asthma because it takes all
this calcium and delivers it all the way
into the tissues and also the fish oils
now fish oils are really really good I
love cod liver oil but if you have any
problems with your memory I would
recommend something called D H a you can
get that from the health of stored eh a
that's a type of fish oil that is very
high in a certain type of good fat that
supports the brain it's good for
attention problems it's good for
fertility it's good for the retina it's
good for the heart
the skin so that would be a good fat to
take to but good column oil would be
very very essential if you if you want
to protect yourself from too much
calcium so that's that's what I
recommend for the vitamins but here's
here's the more likely problem that
people have they're taking these
vitamins already but they don't have
enough bile from the gallbladder your
gallbladder is right here and it
produces something called bile B il-8
not bowel but bile bile helps you break
down fat specifically fat soluble
vitamins a d e and K and F so if you
don't have a gall bladder or you're
bloated all the time or you have
constipation which means you don't have
enough file or you have a right shoulder
pain those are all symptoms of a lack of
I'll then go ahead and take some bile
and then you'll actually start absorbing
these fats and vitamins and all of a
sudden things start really working so we
want to give the remedy but make sure
that you can absorb the remedy as well
okay so we got the gall bladder and lack
of magnesium that's a common thing
because magnesium is the opposing
mineral to calcium so magnesium will
help drive calcium down because they
teeter-totter so magnesium is not a bad
thing to take to help these conditions
as well so if you really look at the big
picture calcium is influenced by
vitamins minerals and other things like
pH so a little bit information is might
be too dangerous because you'll hear
that oh yeah I've lost a bone and I need
to take calcium but you don't understand
that there's other parts to this puzzle
alkalinity and this is another myth that
people always talk about that everyone
is too acid and we need to alkalize
everyone that is a really big myth and
you should watch the video in alcohol on
pH on my blog because if you are under a
lot of stress and you have a high level
of stress hormone called cortisol from
the adrenal over time that will make you
very very alkaline in the blood yet your
ph of your urine is too acid so when I
talk about pH I'm not talking about your
urine or your saliva I'm talking about
the blood and it's very very hard to
detect that but one way you can detect
it is if you have a lot of arthritis and
cell can calcium problems that's right
so if your body is especially your blood
is too alkaline you won't be able to
transport the calcium properly so Akana
and that would also apply to like if
someone's getting older and their
stomach acids are not as strong Lex
let's say they're losing your stomach
acid
they can't absorb all this calcium so it
plugs everything up and that's a very
common cause as well or if you have a
stressed out person your body starts
getting alkaline you start to helping
all these symptoms because you can't
absorb and transport the calcium because
your pH is off one of the simple
remedies for this is apple cider vinegar
a teaspoon in a glass of water I would
do you could probably put it in all of
your water through the day as you drink
it because it will actually start to
bring the pH down more acidic and start
mobilizing the calcium out of the
tissues I mean think about outside of
of an ancient remedy for insomnia and
even pain and rhythm as high blood
pressure cramps yeah the reason why it
works is because it mobilizes calcium so
I hope you enjoyed this video and I will
see you in the next one